got a wild story to start off to 7 30
here the rental car company hertz is
facing allegations from dozens of
customers who say they were falsely
arrested because hertz reported the cars
that they had rented were stolen
some of these individuals were even
thrown in jail now the company which
recently emerged from bankruptcy insists
that virtually all of these claims are
quote meritless it also says that they
should not be allowed to proceed in
court the claims have been on hold
through completion of the bankruptcy
case but today a judge will hear
arguments from both sides and our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner has been looking into all of
it strange bizarre story here anna good
morning
yeah good morning tony and the basic
question as you said is whether these
cases will ever be heard in a courtroom
that's up to the bankruptcy judge to
decide now hertz argues that for various
technical legal reasons they should not
proceed but some of the people with
claims against hertz are coming forward
to tell their stories because they say
they deserve a chance at justice
the police stop houston's james toland
says left him in fear for his life
happened at the end of a work day late
last year i'm actually heading home from
completing a project for one of my
customers he was driving a pickup truck
rented from hertz his fiancee crystal
carter we used to rent cars from hertz
all the time for james's renovation
company in 2020 i believe we rented
probably 12 times but on december 23 at
about 10 p.m tolin says police lights
flashed behind him and i just got pulled
over
over a loudspeaker police ordered him
out of the car then told him to lift up
his shirt and back up toward them as i
turn around i see both officers
train the guns on me and you still at
this point have no idea why i have no
clue what did that feel like it was just
terrifying it was bad actually i was
really thinking that i wasn't going to
make it home
tolen says officers handcuffed him then
told him he was driving a stolen car he
said yeah bro you you know possession of
a stolen vehicle i was like that's
impossible i rent from hers i'm a
contractor so they think that
might be a felon i'm just a contractor
tollen begged the officers to look at
his rental contract where he says he was
listed as an authorized driver after
seeing that he says an officer called
hertz and that's when i heard the
officer telling him like hey do you know
what you you know guys put this guy
through um
he's here for a stolen vehicle his his
contract is is valid we're going to give
him back the vehicle and you guys need
to get a better system this is the
officer talking to this guy from first
you guys need to get a better system
yeah this guy could have lost his life
they say they later found out hertz had
given them a car the company had
reported stolen three months before they
rented you a car
that they had told police was stolen
right when you realized
that they had given you
oh i see it already i was hot
hot
like we rented several times from them
that year
several there too of 165 hertz customers
nationwide who have claims pending in
bankruptcy court saying they were
falsely arrested and in some cases
jailed because hertz filed police
reports saying they're legitimately
rented vehicles were stolen everything
turned into a mess
just disaster
philadelphia area contractor john iu
rented a vehicle in april of 2019. we
needed an extra truck we rented a truck
from hertz he says he told hertz agents
it would be a long-term rental and they
told him to call each week to extend
which he says he did saving these
screenshots and making recordings now
filed in court i need an extension for
another week on the dodge ram
yes euros that it went through i would
call i would extend they would charge it
i would see it and they would say you're
good to go till next monday on may 24th
hertz put through a charge of more than
three hundred dollars on may 28th
unknown to him ayub says hurts filed a
theft report and even though the twenty
three hundred dollars showed paid in his
bank account the next day hertz didn't
pull that police report back four days
later he was arrested right in front of
his house they ended up charging me with
a felony after learning ayub had paid
for the car his lawyer says prosecutors
dropped the charges how do you have a
receipt in your pocket and still get
arrested for stealing the car we asked
hertz for an on-camera interview the
company declined hertz told us in a
statement the vast majority of these
cases involve renters who were many
weeks or even months overdue returning
vehicles and who stopped communicating
with us well beyond the scheduled due
date it said situations where vehicles
are reported to the authorities are very
rare and happen only after exhaustive
attempts to reach the customer as to
pulling back police reports once payment
is made or the vehicle is returned hertz
last year told the philadelphia enquirer
that the reports were valid when they
were filed and it was up to law
enforcement to decide what to do with
the case hertz also told us the opposing
side's attorneys have a track record of
making baseless claims that blatantly
misrepresent the facts in response
claimant's attorney francis alexander
malafi told us it's hertz trying to hide
what he calls a corporate disaster
they've been aware of this for years
and instead of doing the right thing and
addressing it
they're trying to sweep this under the
rug even through bankruptcy you're
saying they're turning legitimate
renters
into criminals
right
and it's wrong
it goes deeper than that
well hertz obviously disagrees with that
the company told us that the company
cares deeply about its customers and
successfully provides rental vehicles
for tens of millions of travelers each
year the company has not responded to
tollen and carter's claims regarding
iube they told the philadelphia inquirer
last year that either they did not have
a record of his rentals or some of them
of his rental extensions i should say or
some were not approved nate
anna thank you so much wow hurt's got
some explaining to do yeah and if you
imagine if you're mr told listen we're
not making light of it but i did have to
say i got a big kick out of kristin
carter's expression when she was taught
when they asked her the question about
what hers had said we all know that
expression and we all know what that
means so we've we heard you kristen
carter i heard it loud and clear yeah
i don't have enough yes and you ain't
telling the truth
but he could have lost his life you
really could have yeah when the police
are calling hurts and saying you had to
fix your system yeah i didn't hear in
that statement them saying there are
instances where we need to change our
policy or our practices this doesn't
happen because one time is too many it's
a dangerous situations you just hope
that somebody on the other side of the
phone is doing their job correctly